foreign
[Music]
that's gonna be a quick no for bats then
you yelled I shall spread news far and
wide of your cowardly capitulation which
will call into question the size of your
sexual member sure it's wider than it's
long but let's not bring body shaming
into this red white and gold Cena you
dare call me Xena I am Princess Diana of
the mascara princess of the Amazons
known to the world as
I'm glad you brought up your fun little
fighty name because I've been wondering
what this weird lady with a metal
headband is doing on our super team wow
this TR
stand any language present or
throw it real far okay so to recap you
have a metal hat that's like Duolingo
and a bad boomerang
your whole outfit it doesn't make sense
well you think my outfit's stupid you
took the time to add ears to your helmet
yeah but there's little walkie-talkie
and antenna in there so wearing hearing
aids and it goes up into the pointy
point and these are like little am
antennas sometimes I pick up wait wait
don't tell me it feels elaborate and
unnecessary and I don't think you should
criticize what I'm wearing no my armor
is crafted by Greek gods and at least I
don't use it to give myself fake abs
fake abs fake abs you're out of line
under the ABS that are on it there's
Bruce jiggly Bruce
and then there's ABS what what are those
bracelets these bracelets are made out
of the strongest metal on Earth
amazonium they are so strong they can
stop bullets great my wrists have body
armor too but you know what else has my
vital organs and I'm sorry but you're an
Amazon and the metal that you discovered
you called it amazonium
that's like Avatar unobtainium bad oh
really how long did it take you to come
up with Batman man who likes bats at
surprisingly long time
My First Choice was Betty McChicken
punch I have an upside down guy and
they'd go who are you I'd go barely be
kicking punch but they kept laughing I
killed a lot of those guys I thought you
never killed anybody it was the early
years I was work shopping I'm sorry this
and all the other reasons I mentioned
that's why you're [__] fired
what you're [__] fired there's one
thing you've forgotten about
my lasso oh no I didn't forget about
your last show the whole world forgot
what a lasso is you say lasso to anyone
under 40 in this country they all think
you mean an endlessly optimistic soccer
coach it has its uses
yo the lasso of hastia compels you to
tell the truth it is pointless and
painful to resist oh this is in painful
y'all
it hurts a surprise in your mouth what
is your secret identity Bruce Wayne but
that's just one layer I have a deeper
secret identity [__] dick Daniels
City Daniels is the real me okay what is
your big
your big boob Shadow no matter how many
girl push-ups I do there's still a good
Eclipse under each of my nips what is
your deepest darkest secret I could have
saved my parents I just had a Game Boy
at the time oh God why didn't I put down
the Kirby have you ever had a sexual
fantasy about anyone in the league no
yes
Flash
look not into dudes but I'm a porn
addict it's more about novelty than
what's actually doing it for me plus he
could give me a handy so fast my dick
would blur and smoke gross I'm gonna
tell everyone on the Justice League
about your smoking [__] fantasy if
you don't keep me on the team I don't
care I do care I Define Myself by other
people's opinions I thought so I'd do an
impression of what I think they want and
it's exhausting
psychologically
training also you're [__] fired and
you know I mean it
would I lie to you
foreign
[Music]